welcome to best car fixes this is
muhammad haroon it is please subscribe
share and like
as hyundai sonata 2013
hybrid
we are trying to add a key as usual the
key have an exit
that's the place where you put the key
and
let's see if uh the proximity
this is a push button
i put the hazard light on you see that
key not detect
push again
the key is not detect
so we are going to
see if we can
uh
check this with this car
and do it or unprogram it except
so what are you gonna do so now go to
asian car
go to hyundai
after hyundai
let me close the door from the noise
what do you want automatic selection
maybe he asked you to put the vin number
i don't believe you you'll be able to
get the vin number because ignition is
close
exit
manual
s sonata it have a lot of name so
because this car is hybrid
but even the hybrid it have sonata
hybrid
let me start with this 16 to 19 no
let me see this one
this is not it two
16 to 19 no
let me see this one 11 to 15 it could be
smart key
okay 2011 to 15 smart key and it's a
hybrid car
i'm going to open the closet driver door
i gotta go to smart
scan
i just wanted to scan it for me take
take my time a little bit
i tried to do it with or tech it gave me
hard time
see now i was able to read all the
information
so what you need to do now here maybe
the first thing to do is to get a pin
code
so now read a pin code
create pin smart
by obd2
it's okay
i have to connect no bluetooth i have to
connect a hardwire between here
and here so stay with us
i put
uh a hard wire
i would say okay
hazard on open close driver door once
how's it on say okay
so now maybe we're gonna wait here
for a quiet bit to get
the information right
establish communication i know you need
internet
hazard is working
communication is spinning
i'm gonna wait here maybe take a minute
two minutes three minutes
right now it's 3 48.
four minute i have so i'm gonna stop
here and see how much how long before it
will be ready after two minutes or one
minute
he asked me
um for one minute if the vehicle have a
slot
if
it is a vehicle with the key slot please
insert the key into the key slot if all
key lost please click ok to continue
okay
yes i put the key already in there
as usual
i get the password wow yeah
very fast
six nine three seven
i'm gonna write it back some way
if you don't write it also it will be
there six nine three seven
five okay
so okay
now what you need to do
skip this
okay lost
and it's very this function will support
all key
say start
function will support add key all key
laws perform the function will erase all
keys say yes
put the key in the ignition in the slot
i put it
success
693756 say yes
the enter security code is please
say yes
success
insert the key is already there
program succeed would you like to
program another one say no
number is one please
please exit the system to the vehicle
selection menu and check if the key is
programmed
program successful is
exit
you can
before here let's say we have two key
if we go back
and then we're gonna take our stuff out
take the key out
take this piece out
okay
now
look here
hey set the top
okay
[Music]
now if you can push the brake and push
it one time
it will be ready
and now here is out
car is running maybe it will not work
save time why
the car is running and this happens okay
honestly i try to use or check maybe i
don't know how to use it well
but in
it took me so crazy time i go up and
down left or right
you guy with me when i was doing it
maybe
even reading the password is not there
[Music]
and this card is hybrid
blue drive green drive
is good
so now what we need to do is maybe we
have to
see if we can cut this key
please subscribe share and like and if
you have any problem feel free to ask
this is muhammad haroon idris and this
is apply
for all keys with this because this key
it can be for
hyundai
sonata elentra a lot of under any car
with this
this one will work with it
okay now with this one now if you just
want to go now out
you